oh celery juice
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by beltbar
and we'll be reviewing another harper's
bazaar
food diaries by american actress kate
hudson
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor buildbar so
if you are new here welcome uh but of
course my regular viewers know that i
very much love these bars because i
think they taste like a chocolate bar
and you know protein bars are just such
an easy convenient source of protein for
those
really super crazy days and
we are living in a pandemic so i know we
all got
a lot of those i have tried a lot of
protein bars in my day and i find most
of them taste like chalk
but these ones oh no they actually taste
like a chocolate bar
and i think kate would also approve just
saying
all right let's see what flavor we gonna
get into
today it's so hard to chew sometimes
what am i in the mood for something
super chocolatey something more fruity
i don't know
coconut almond yeah let's let's throw
all of my favorite flavors together
this one right here 18 grams of protein
i think i've tried this one before i
can't remember
took a big bite it's gonna take a while
don't judge me a few moments later
tastes like a vacation
and i'm here for it these are a lower
sugar bar for those who are looking for
that but of course
if i was having this as my post-workout
snack or part of my post-workout meal
i'd probably pair it with a source of
carbs like some fruit
oatmeal some toast etc but if you want
to give these bars a try
check out the link in the description
and use my promo code for 15
off of your order also super quick
before we dive in you can pause the
screen
or check out the description to look at
my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating
i will be evaluating meals based on
their nutritional mira alone which
as we know says very little about their
overall value
so if that is not supporting your food
journey
by all means sit this one out and of
course don't forget to subscribe to this
channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on an episode
all right folks let's get eating am i
gonna get up
15 minutes from now or am i just gonna
go back to sleep
and then i drink water the fact that
there isn't
lemon in this water is borderline
triggering for me like could this day of
eating
possibly be [ __ ] free
i do not eat first thing in the morning
the first thing i do in the morning
is i have celery juice never mind and uh
if anybody does celery juice on an empty
stomach
they know why because it's a joyous
morning activity so the joyous activity
that kate is referring to
is pooping of course it is joyous
gotta love a good poop celery is rich in
a
fodmap called mannitol which actually
pulls
water into the bowels which can cause
diarrhea
cramping and the urgency to go now most
people can tolerate a little celery in
their salad
but just two stalks of celery are
considered high fodmap by the monash
institute so
if you drink a whole glass of celery
juice comprised of an entire
bunch of celery well
yeah for some folks you're going to want
to stay close to home
it's coming out of me like lava two soft
boiled eggs
with some sourdough and butter and
avocado with olive oil and sea salt
classic and a great sounding balanced
breakfast
so we got protein in the eggs fiber in
the sourdough and
healthy fats in the avocado and the
olive oil
i guess there's a reason why this is
like the pandemic breakfast of
wellness influencers everywhere it's
just pretty great
oatmeal with like almond butter and
banana and maybe some blueberries
some maple syrup cinnamon chia seeds
maybe some walnuts in there so this also
sounds really good if you're craving the
kind of sweet
breakfast option so we've got fiber rich
carbs and the oats and fruit
healthy fats and protein in the chia
almond butter
walnuts all the good things love it
delish so yeah we've got some options if
we're feeling
the sweet or if we're feeling the savory
walnuts are
i feel like they're underrated i feel
like more people use
almonds or cashews but a walnut a walnut
in your oatmeal
is really i'm personally not a walnut
fan
i think they're a little bitter and dry
just saying
but they are probably one of the most
nutritious
nuts you can eat so compared with the
almonds and cashews that she cited
and actually all other nuts too walnuts
have
more heart-healthy omega-3s which is
really a unique
selling feature in the nut world so a
great addition to a bowl of oats
on the go i'm going to just get a
smoothie
lunch ish a smoothie
for me would be like a protein based
drink i like the chocolatey type flavors
like banana and almond butter and
chocolate simple but i would say
relatively
light lunch option but if there was ever
a three ingredient combo that delivered
in the protein shake
category it would be chocolate protein
powder banana
and almond butter or peanut butter i
like peanut butter
but anyways we've got protein in the
protein powder
fiber in the fruit and the almond butter
and those healthy fats in the almonds as
well
solid option but again like i said not a
very substantial lunch
if she was feeling like in the sweet
brunchy mood
i would personally want to maybe throw
in some veg to that smoothie
and also start with a source of
carbohydrates like some toast
or some yogurt and fruit chop salad
that's kind of a go-to for me i do
extra salami no cheese cucumbers
no tomatoes basil and
extra dressings so not really a chopped
salad
what is this i don't know more like a
charcuterie board with like some sauce
on there
but sounds a delicious
charcuterie board with sauce at that now
you guys all know that i'm all about
adding in nutritious ingredients to
build a more nutrient-dense
meal so if she want to keep that salami
and dressing
even if this did add and increase the
saturated fat and sodium in the meal
i would suggest just throwing in some
more nutritious ingredients to
bulk this up so some great nutrients
dense
chopped salad friendly options that she
could kind of throw in there to make up
for the items that she omitted
would be things like chickpeas eggs
olives
bell peppers avocado corn radishes
etc and also pairing it with maybe some
pita
or throwing in some quinoa or faro or
another grain
just to bulk up the carbs to make it a
little bit more satiating
i always try to find at least a half
hour to work out i think it's important
to try to take
time to move your body most days of the
week
and it doesn't need to be like a
strenuous boot camp
but even a walk around the neighborhood
or some youtube
yoga for example would be a really great
addition to your day
and there are days when even something
like this is not gonna happen and that
is
totally okay i think it's equally
important
to cut yourself some slack not let it
trigger
like restrictive compensatory behaviors
and just carry on with your week as
usual
just remember that missing a workout
here or there
is going to have zero impact on your
health status
or weight it's all about the overall
behavioral patterns is there an animal
in my bush
that's what she said i don't know what
you're talking about i had to i try not
to be a big snacker but i love a snack
why is the word snack so triggering to
so many health enthusiasts like
why is it automatically a bad word
i think that diet culture has hijacked
the concept of snacking
to become synonymous with like a treat
or
ultra processed food but really
a snack to me is just like a mini meal
it's just a bridge meal to get you to
that more substantial sit down
experience
so ideally your snack includes you know
the hunger crushing combo of fiber
protein and fat it can actually look
identical to
a meal but just smaller and maybe a
little bit simpler
so there should of course be room for
fun foods too in your diet
but this to me is different than a snack
and this language becomes
a lot more important when you're raising
kids
for whom snacks are really key
but let's see what her snacks of choice
are you cannot stay away from chips and
salsa
and simple mills makes an amazing
cheddar almond flour it's like a
cheez-it
but healthy okay so we need to vote
in the chip dip trifecta
what would you choose salsa guac
or sour cream guac is number one for me
and also it would make the snack more
satiating of course because
of the fiber and healthy fats in the
avocado
but salsa is a close second
i don't like sour cream i don't know
don't come at me
it just doesn't have enough flavor for
me
i don't know i i i think sour cream just
needs like some salt or something
so i guess if the chips are salty enough
it balances itself up
i'm here for it but yeah let me know
below
anyways as for the simple mills cheddar
crackers
these crackers are made out of almond
flour and
i actually really like them too but if
you want to see
how they stack up against a typical
cheez-it
let's take a look now the healthier
almond flour version actually has
slightly more calories
the same amount of protein and fiber and
almost the same
amount of sodium yes it's gluten-free
where the classic cheez-its are
not but if you really want your
cheez-its and
you're eating almond flour cheese
crackers reluctantly because you think
it's a much
healthier choice i'm just here to tell
you
that maybe it's not super sound logic
so choose the cracker that you love and
if you want
you can make it even more nutritious by
pairing it with a more substantial
source of protein
fiber or healthy fats like nuts
seeds or actual cheese just saying
i try to get everybody to do five
between 5 30 and 6.
if that doesn't happen for me i i like
to eat before seven unless i'm going out
you know which
nobody i don't do that anymore welcome
to the geriatric dinner club folks
but also this kind of just like comes
with the parenthood
territory i think anyways i'm definitely
interested to hear about some of her
family meals one of my favorite meals
nutmeg chicken it's shallots
it's lemon fresh herbs brown the chicken
in the oven
and you make this like nutmeg gravy and
you
and rice that sounds incredible
love a good roast chicken and i'm really
intrigued by this nutmeg
gravy situation definitely an unusual
pairing
but i am here for it and honestly
chicken is always a really great
easy lean protein dinner main to pair
with maybe some rose veggies
or like she does some rice so any kind
of starch potatoes
whole grains rice love it this sounds
like a really great family meal
sweet corn pasta that my kids love it's
pancetta peas corn white wine
butter and olive oil and cream
oh that right there totally my style
perfect summer pasta dish and
while i have no qualms about just
enjoying a carb and cream
combo like this straight up if you want
to balance this out a bit
you could throw in some canned chickpeas
for some protein or some leftover
chicken
and toss in tons of fresh summer squash
and zucchini
but yeah sounds really really good just
as it is too
i want to mess with perfection we had
the greatest matzo ball soup that
grandma used to make and then mom made
this chicken and dumplings that was my
grandma's recipe
that was like it's out of this world and
then mom also makes a biscuit and gravy
as a jewish mama i would describe
those three things as like jewish meets
southern comfort food
warm kind of salty hearty
and let's be real kind of constipated
but honestly
i am here for it a good biscuit is
worth being a little backed up
it's sparkling water all day long okay
but let's talk about sparkling water for
a second
so a lot of people ask me what those
natural flavors in sparkling water are
and if they're like toxic or what now
this was an especially hot topic after
there was a
class action lawsuit against lacroix
or lacroix or whatever around whether or
not
said natural flavors were in fact
natural so to start
natural is kind of an ambiguous and
controversial term in the food industry
basically anything can be labeled as
natural as long as it doesn't contain
any added color artificial flavors or
synthetic substances
but the fda specifically defines natural
flavors
as the essential oil olio resin essence
or extractive
protein hydrolysate distillate
or any product of roasting heating or
enzymolysis which contains the flavoring
constituents derived from spice fruit
or fruit juice vegetable or vegetable
juice
edible yeast herb bark bud
root leaf or similar plant material meat
seafood poultry eggs dairy products or
fermentation of products
thereof whose significant function in
food is
flavoring rather than nutritional
that one was a doozy and reading that is
enough for most people to just say
what the does that mean and either just
conclude that it's healthy or it's toxic
depending which way you sway in the
absence of useful
evidence-based information so
here's what we know these natural
flavors
are classified under the fda's category
of
generally recognized as safe or grass
and if you look deeper at most of the
popular sparkling water companies like
lacroix
and bubbly most specifically do say
that their flavor is coming from
extracts or essences
from fruits and vegetables but as a
general rule of thumb on this
manufacturers don't actually have to
reveal their sources
so we don't really know where these
natural flavors come from not to mention
the fda's definition of natural flavors
suggests that while these substances do
have to have
natural origins they can be chemically
altered to create
a desirable flavor so how you interpret
this really is up to you
but we do have no evidence that these
flavors are doing any harm so until that
changes
i'm gonna keep drinking my beloved
bubbly
and kate you can too i could do this
forever i want to talk about
food all day long anything from the foie
gras
to the chicken to the shoestring
potatoes how much time do we have
because i could keep going
oh oh my god i am having major
foodie wanderlust fomo right now
oh i just want to travel and eat all the
things guys
let's beat this cobit thing all right
back to the food i really try not to
late night snack
but i do again you know a late night
snack
doesn't have to be bad it's not that
food consumed
after 8 pm automatically turns to fat
but i will say that research on our
circadian alignment does suggest that
insulin sensitivity is at its peak
during
daytime hours so if we can align our
food intake with these hours
it can have some benefit for our
metabolism and glucose response having
said that
for most people this would be splitting
hairs
and not likely to cause any major shifts
on the scale
so whether you eat 500 calories in ice
cream above your caloric needs at
8 a.m or 8 p.m it's going to have
approximately the same net of a 500
calorie
surplus everyone can't seem to get
through a night without having like a
big snack at 2 am so
yeah i'm hoping that kind of shifts and
works
itself out when i stop pumping in the
night but let's see what she's having
for her snack yeah and my late night
snack is always going to be
in the ice cream department same and
you know just know that reaching for
foods that are higher in sugar salt and
fat in the evening
is actually incredibly common we don't
know for sure why this
is but part of it is likely that we've
been socialized
to curl up on the couch with like a bag
of chips and a pint of ben and jerry's
rather than a bowl of celery and carrots
i mean an entire genre of young adult
media has been built
on this classic rom-com trope but it
also may have to do with the fact that
at the end of the night and at the end
of the day we are tired you know our
inhibitions are down
and for those with tumultuous
relationships with food
we're kind of just too exhausted to
restrict anymore
and so out comes the ice cream and
down the hatch she goes they do great
oat milk
ice creams now so i try to stay
non-dairy because it's a little bit
better for me
so i'm not sure if kate hudson is
completely dairy-free
for a specific reason and that's why
she's suggesting that it's
better for her to go with the oat milk
based yogurt versus
the regular but generally speaking
if you're going to eat ice cream i say
choose the one that is most enjoyable to
you
if we're to compare the labels of my
favorite ice cream flavor
ben and jerry's netflix and chilled
which is oh my gosh
it is so good um the dairy-free version
has 10 calories and 2 grams of fat less
but it actually has more sugar and
less protein per serving as well so
is it really healthier not necessarily
for
everyone depending on your health goals
but
if you don't digest dairy very well and
you can still derive that same amount of
pleasure from
the dairy free version then of course
it is the better option for you
mint chip i love because it's refreshing
but i really like like a dolce de leche
type of and with chocolate chips i think
kate and i are kind of kindred spirits
because
i think we like the same ice cream
flavors like
dolce de leche is life and mint
chocolate chip was always my favorite as
a kid
and i still do enjoy me a good mint
chip but leave me a comment below on
your favorite flavor because
i don't know i could read about and talk
about ice cream all day
long tell me what's your flavor but
don't tell me you like vanilla because
just know why would you choose vanilla
when you can have
vanilla with something else in it i just
don't understand
i'm not a big fan of like rice puddings
anything that gets too like i don't know
creamy i know the word she's looking for
and it's gloopy right i mean
i love a good rice pudding i was raised
on
rice pudding but there is definitely
some interesting
textural contrast going on so i
understand
that rice pudding is a little
controversial but you know what's even
more controversial raisins in your rice
pudding
are you team raisin or team no raisin
because i'm a purist like nothing else
other than
rice and cream and sugar and whatever
the hell else maybe some egg yolks or
something
nothing else cinnamon you can put
cinnamon and rice pudding but nothing
else
no raisins no chocolate chips no other
weird ingredients
thank you very much okay well i'm
getting a little bit off topic
but what can we say about kate's diet
and relationship with food well i think
we're seeing a lot of the classic
wellness culture staples so
celery juice protein oatmeal protein
shake and the avocado toast
what i like is that these are juxtaposed
against some
comfort soul food options like the
chicken and biscuits and the
sweet corn and bacon pasta chips and
salsa
and a good roast chicken with a rich
gravy
i think it's clear to me that kate loves
food
as evidenced by her like waxing poetic
about all of her favorite food cities
and foodie travels but she's also
interested in
taking care of her body through daily
movement and nutrient dense food
is she influenced by diet culture likely
i mean
the woman owns an athleisure line so
this is kind of part of her brand
but unlike other wellness influencers
like guena paltrow
i get the sense that she's probably a
lot more chill
at least as far as family meals go
i don't think she's like putting her
kids on detoxes or super restrictive
diets
and it does sound like she's
prioritizing family meals which
i think is so important as for
suggestions
it's hard to really get a sense of
exactly how kate's meals come together
from a format like this but if i had any
suggestion
it would maybe be to bulk up that midday
meal
by adding in some carbs so you know some
toast to the smoothie
or some grains to the salad this might
help make the meal a lot more satiating
so that she wouldn't feel the need to
overdo it on chips and dip in the
afternoon
i would also just remind her and also
all of you
that there's nothing wrong with snacking
but we can also make our snack more
satiating
by focusing on the hunger crushing combo
of fiber
protein and fat so rather than getting
rid of the chips if she loves the chips
maybe pairing them with a source of fat
like guacamole to just
balance things out and make it more
satiating and on that note that is all
that i have for you guys today
thank you again to builtbar for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye and for more great videos like this
check out the link right here
you